here
yep
misty mystic
yes
um
um
foreign
thanks
good morning folks
hope you all had a happy thanksgiving
able to get together with your family
and friends
and uh
it was great to see uh so many families
getting together this thanksgiving
after being a part last year
and we have much to be grateful for as a
nation
when i was elected i said i would always
be honest with you so today i want to
take a few moments to talk about the new
covert variant
first identified
last week in southern africa
it's called the omnicron
it is the uh to their credit the
scientific community in south africa
quickly notified the world of the
emergence of this new variant
this kind of transparency is to be
encouraged and applauded
because it increases our ability to
respond quickly to any new threats
and that's exactly what we did
the very day the world health
organization identified the new variant
i took immediate steps to restrict
travel from countries in southern africa
but while we had that travel
restrictions can slow the speed of
omnicron
it cannot prevent it but here's what it
does
it gives us time gives us time to take
more actions
to move quicker to make sure people
understand you have to get your vaccine
you have to get the shot you have to get
to get the booster if you're the sooner
or later we're going to see cases of
this new variant here in the united
states we'll have to face this new
threat just so we face those that come
before it
today
there are three messages about the new
variant that i want the american people
to hear
first
this variant is a cause for concern not
a cause for panic
we have the best vaccine in the world
the best medicines the best scientists
and we're learning more every single day
and we'll fight this variant with
scientific
and
and knowledgeable actions and speed
not chaos and confusion and we have more
tools today to fight the variant than
we've ever had before
from vaccines to boosters to vaccines
for children five years and older and
much more
a year ago america was floundering
against the first variant of covet
we beat that variant significantly
and then we got hit by a far more
powerful threat the delta variant but we
took action
and now we're seeing deaths from delta
come down we'll fight the you know and
look we're going to fight and beat this
new variant as well
we're learning more about this new
variant every single day and as we learn
more we're going to share that
information with the american people
candidly and promptly
second
the best protection i know you're tired
of hearing me say this the best
protection against this new variant or
any of the of the variants out there the
ones we've been dealing with already
is getting fully vaccinated
and getting a booster shot
most americans are fully vaccinated but
not yet boosted
if you're 18 years or over
and got fully vaccinated before june the
first
go get the booster shot today
they're free
and they're available at 80 000
locations coast to coast
a fully vaccinated booster person is the
most protected against covet
do not wait
go get your booster if it's time for you
to do so
and if you are not vaccinated now is the
time to get vaccinated and take your
children to be vaccinated
every child age five or older can get
safe effective vaccines now
while it will be a few weeks before we
know everything we need to know about
how strongly
the existing vaccines protect against
new variant
dr fauci is with me today
our medical team
and believe that the vaccines will
continue to provide a degree of
protection against severe disease
and as additional protections please
wear your mask when you're indoors
in public settings around other people
it protects you and protects those
around you
third
in the event hopefully unlikely that
updated vaccinations or boosters are
needed to respond to this new variant we
will accelerate their development and
deployment with every available tool
i want to reiterate
dr fauci believes that the current
vaccines provide at least some
protection against a new variant and the
booster strengthen that protection
significantly
we do not yet believe that additional
measures will be needed
but
so that we are prepared
if needed my team is already working
with officials at pfizer and badern and
johnson and johnson to develop
contingency plans for vaccines or
boosters if needed
and i will also direct the fda and the
cdc to use the fastest process available
without cutting any corners for safety
to get such vaccines approved and on the
market if needed
and we'll do that the same way any
modifications are needed or current
treatments need used to help those with
who get ill with the copa virus
look
i'm uh i'm sparing no effort and
removing all roadblocks to keep the
american people safe
all of this is confusing
to a lot of people but if it's confusing
to you let me close with this simple
message
if you are vaccinated
but still worried about the new variant
get your booster
if you aren't vaccinated
get that shot go get that first shot
my team at the white house will provide
me with daily updates this week and on
thursday i'll be putting forward a
detailed strategy outlining how we're
going to fight covet this winter
not with shutdowns or lockdowns
but with more widespread vaccinations
boosters testing and more
i promised every american
that there will be always be the latest
vaccines available and the booster shots
available to them and for free and
everywhere available
every single american free of charge
and i will keep that commitment
but we need to do more than vaccinated
americans
to beat the pandemic we have to
vaccinate the world as well and america
is leading that effort
we've shipped for free
more vaccines to other countries than
all other countries in the world
combined
over
275 million vaccines
to 110 countries
now we need the rest of the world to
step up as well let me be clear
not a single vaccine shot americans ever
sent to the rest of the world will ever
come at the expense of any american
i will always make sure that our people
are protected first
but vaccinating the world is just one
more tool
and how we need to meet our moral
obligation as americans and how to best
protect americans as well the delta
variants and now the omnicron
variant
all emerged elsewhere in the world
so we can't let up until the world is
vaccinated we're protecting americans by
doing that
as well
as we continue this effort let's
remember where we stand
we're in a very different place
as we enter the month of december
this month
compared to where we were last uh last
september last christmas
last christmas fewer than one percent of
american adults were vaccinated
this christmas the number will be over
71 percent
including more than 86 percent of
seniors
last christmas our children were at risk
without a vaccine this christmas we have
safe and effective vaccines for children
ages 5 and older
with more than 19 million children and
counting now vaccinated
last year a majority of schools were
closed this year 99 of our schools are
open
let me reiterate once more
we also now have booster shots that
provide extra protection
they're free and convenient
there is still time to get your first
two shots
or your booster shot or get your
children vaccinated before christmas all
three are available can be done before
christmas
if you and your family are fully
vaccinated
you can celebrate the holidays much more
safely
and given where we were last year that's
a blessing that none of us should take
for granted
we're throwing everything we can at this
virus
tracking it from every angle
and that's what we have to keep doing
that's how we reopened our country
that's how we re-open our businesses
that's how we reopen our schools that's
how even with the pandemic
we've generated a record job creation
and record economic growth in this
country
we've moved forward in the face of covet
19.
we have moved forward in the face of the
delta variant
and we move forward now in the face the
omnicron variant as well so thank you
and god bless our troops and i hope you
all have i'll be speaking before them
but a merry christmas as we approach it
uh questions should america be worried
sir let me call on nancy bloomberg
thank you so much president biden do you
think that
other countries will be reluctant to um
report variants or other strains given
the travel ban that you put so quickly
on south africa
no i i i don't think so i don't think
that's what's going to happen
and i want to again the reason for the
immediate travel ban
is there were a significant number of
cases unlike any other country all the
few around south africa in the world
we needed time to give people an
opportunity to say get that vaccination
now before it heads it's going to move
around the world i think it's almost
inevitable there will be at some point
that
that strain here in the united states
but i don't i don't think anyone's going
to be reluctant to report
we have also moved to uh do more for
example we've provided more vaccines as
i said than all other countries in the
world combined
and we provided significant vaccines as
well to south africa in that region
matter of fact south africa doesn't need
any more vaccine they're having trouble
getting it out into people's arms and
the reluctance is there but no i don't
think it's going to have that effect
on alexis alexis
alex reuters yes thank you so much mr
president i wanted to ask if the u.s is
doing anything to screen international
travels for this variant and what is
being done if anything internally to see
if the virus this variant has already
arrived
well there's a lot being done uh i'm
going to turn to dr fauci to answer the
last question about what's being done
doc
thank you mr president we already have
in place when people come into the
united states they have to be tested
before they get on and they have to show
vaccination uh
documentation so even before omnicorn
came in we have a situation where we'll
be able to test and talking about
testing
for fortunately for us the pcrs that we
mostly use would pick up this very
unusual
variant that has a real large
constellation of mutations fortunately
for us that the pcrs that we do do pick
it up
and uh we're following extremely closely
the medical community of the kova team
uh
any
developments as it relates to how severe
it is how quickly due to how quickly it
spreads how dangerous it is etc we have
more work to do in that area
and
wall street journal
sabrina thank you mr president the uk
europe and a growing number of countries
have confirmed cases of omicron are you
considering additional travel
restrictions on countries where the
variant has been detected and just
separately you've urged americans to
wear masks in indoor public spaces but
many states and cities including
washington dc have listed mass mandates
are you calling on state and local
officials to reinstate mass mandates
uh with regard to the last question the
answer is uh
i
encourage everyone
to
wear a mask when they're indoors in a
crowded circumstance like we are right
now
um
and unless you're eating or speaking at
a microphone
um and
secondly um uh
the
degree of the spread
impacts on whether or not there's a need
for any
travel restriction
but that's not i don't anticipate that
at this point and we'll see we'll see if
that works and so the other alex doesn't
have a heart attack i want to call on
him
no i'm not an alex but i'd love that
question
okay let me ask the other alex
mr president uh is this the new normal
that americans should expect
anticipating future uh potential
variants should we expect intermittent
travel restrictions and potential drops
in the stock market going forward do you
have any words of reassurance that this
won't become the new normal and then for
both you and dr fauci dr apache said
earlier on cbs that uh lockdown
shutdowns are off off the table for uh
restraining kobe going forward you said
that won't be part of your plan on
thursday
but why is that why are you taking that
off the table
well to answer your first question first
the answer is
i expect this not to be the new normal
i expect the new normal to be
everyone ends up getting vaccinated in
the booster shot so we reduce the number
of people who aren't protected to such a
low degree that we're not seeing the
spread of these viruses
now we remain to be seen exactly what
the elements of this particular strain
are but if as
i hope then it's not going to be
fundamentally different
than in the past
um
and uh
in terms of uh what was the second part
of the question are lockdown's off the
table yes for
well because we're able to if people are
vaccinated and wear their mask there's
no need for lockdown
so um my last question yes going on from
from that question uh we've got the
christmas period coming up huge amount
of travel
would you give any thought to domestic
flights requiring tests or vaccine for
people get on planes the same way as
they do for international flights
well at this point that's not been
recommended i would make for my the
scientific community to give me a
recommendation on that are traffic
restrictions too late to be effective
sir given that dr fauci says this new
variant could already be here
you understand the point of the travel
of the restriction
to give us time to get people to get
protection to be vaccinated and get the
booster that's the reason for it
thank you all so very very much i
appreciate it thank you
and i'm sure i'll see you between now
and christmas but hope you had a good
thanksgiving
[Music]
you